be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so Moon Knight was created by writer
Doug mink and artist Don Perlin and made
his debut in werewolf by night number 32
in August of 1975 initially depicted as
a villain Moon Knight was never intended
to make any more appearances beyond this
to issue first encounter with werewolf
by night however according to an
interview with Doug mink on hammock
monsters comm Marvel editor Marv Wolfman
liked the character so much they
suggested mink and pearl into a one-shot
story for Marvel spotlight a book Marvel
used to try out new characters to gauge
their popularity with readers to that
end Moon Knight was featured in issues
number 28 and 29 in 1976 this time a
hero instead of a villain following
these appearances mink began to use Moon
Knight in the backup stories featured in
The Hulk magazine a publication aimed at
more mature magazine audiences that mink
was writing at the time according to
Doug himself the decision to bring Moon
Knight into the magazine was done at the
suggestion of fellow Marvel writer Ralph
Macchio who was a fan of the character
from the Marvel spotlight appearances in
order to fill pages needed for the
magazine later in 1976 Moon Knight
joined the defenders in issue number 47
during David crash run on the book and
would make its final appearances with
the team in issue number 50 because Moon
Knight was proving to be such a popular
character with readers he was given his
first solo ongoing series in 1980 under
the writing of Doug mink with Ville sing
collects on art it is in this series
that moon Knights origin is finally
revealed the man that would eventually
become Moon Knight was born mark specter
the son of a Chicago rabbi who rebelled
against his father's faith and viewed
him as a coward due to his decision to
flee Europe to escape the Holocaust
instead of fighting against the
oppression of his people after a brief
stint as a boxer mark joined the United
States Marine Corps and after receiving
his discharge is hired by the CIA where
he worked alongside his brother Randall
as it would turn out Randall would soon
be revealed to be a traitor that was
illegally trading weapons and would
actually murder Mark's girlfriend in
order to silence her after she found out
a secret as a result this causes mark to
pursue Randall and it seems that in the
ensuing conflict Randall is killed by a
grenade
shortly after this mark became
disillusioned with the CIA and left to
become a mercenary for hire which led
him on a mission in Africa where he
first met French pilot
jean-paul du Chun the chef who mark
would give the name Frenchy would become
one of mark's closest companions as well
as his personal pirate mark's mercenary
career would eventually lead him to
Salima sudan under the employ of a tear
wrists named wild Bushman Wallen Salima
Mark and his team happened upon an
archaeological dig ran by dr. Peter
Albert and his daughter Marlene Bushman
who mark had become disenchanted with
due to his ruthlessness and brutality
wanted to loot the dig site which
uncovered a Pharaoh's tomb
as a result bush kills dr. al rain
leading to a confrontation between mark
and Bushman which results in mark being
defeated and left for dead in the desert
fortunately for spectre Marlene and the
men working for her father laid marks
body at the feet of a statue of khonshu
the Egyptian god of the moon and those
who travel by night who take him to
their temple with Mark seemingly on the
verge of death he's visited by khonshu
in a vision to this end khonshu offers
mark a deal he will allow him to live as
long as he agrees to become Cash's
avatar or his bodily manifestation on
earth and serve as the knight of
vengeance agreeing to the deal mark
Specter Dawn's the biryeo shroud
covering the statue as a cloak before
challenging Bushman to a second battle
and defeating him following this mark
Marlene and Frenchy returned to the
United States bringing the khonshu Idol
with him and mark decides to use his new
lease on life to fight crime as
moonlight in order to accomplish this
mark invest the money he had assembled
as a soldier for hire and turns it into
a small fortune hoping to distance L
from the shady past mark creates a new
identity for himself in the form of
multi-millionaire Steve grant although
mark uses this identity publicly and
lives a life of luxury he realizes that
in order to be an effective crime
fighter he has to maintain a presence on
the street where he can acquire
information about crimes that are being
committed to this end mark creates
another identity this time as a cab
driver named Jake Lockley as Lockley
mark also uses civilians to stay
informed and through these dealings
forges an alliance with a homeless man
named bertrand crowley that will
continue to be an ally throughout moon
night's entire career as minks moon
nights series continued one of the key
components that would define moon out as
a character going forward began to
develop that of Mark specters possible
mental illness this possibility is
demonstrated by the fact that during the
series it's speculated that mark's
encounter with contry was not actually
genuine and instead was simply a
hallucination mark suffered due to his
recent beating at the hands of Bushman
and a subsequent near-death experience
furthermore it was hinted that mark
specter actually suffered from multiple
personality disorder which was his
actual reason for the creation of the
Steve grant and Jake Lockley
personalities however it's been left in
big us as to whether or not marks
vector actually suffered from any mental
disorder while moon night series
initially enjoyed healthy sales numbers
it was ultimately done in from a
decision by Marvel to switch some of
their titles to direct market only
meaning that these titles would only be
available at comic-book specialty shops
and could not be found on newsstands
like most of their books this was done
as part of a strategy by Marvel to grow
the direct market in the business model
of selling books that they did not think
would sell well enough on the newsstands
to come a book stores in a non
returnable basis many of the cost of
unsold books would be absorbed by the
store instead of Marvel allowing the
newsstands to return their unsold copies
to Marvel directly and receive a refund
however this experiment backfired as
Moon Knight saw its numbers drop after
being removed from newsstands and was
canceled with issue number 38 due to
poor sales and so in 1985 Marvel would
give Moon Knight a second solo series in
the form of Moon Knight Fist of the
khonshu written by Allen sellin 'it's
this one removed much of the nuance and
ambiguity from moon knights
characterization opting to paint him as
a more traditional superhero who derived
his supernatural powers from his
encounter with khonshu Moon Knight was
also given a litany of weapons tied to
the egyptian-themed of his character
after he's summoned to Egypt by
country's followers among these weapons
are a golden egg
boom wings throwing irons and most
notably crescent moon-shaped throwing
darts moon ideas of a variety of gadgets
have prompted many fans to draw
comparisons between him and DC's Batman
to the extent that many think of him as
Marvel's attempt to create their own
version of Bruce Wayne unfortunately the
second moon knife series seemed not to
resonate with fans and it lasted only
six issues before being cancelled and so
following this moon knives place on a
roster of the West Coast Avengers a move
which removes him from his allies
Frenchy and Marlene with whom he had
recently ended his romantic relationship
with during his time with the West Coast
Avengers Moon Knight travels back in
time to the year 29 40 BC to rescue the
Avengers who have been trapped in
ancient Egypt while there moon knight
learned that his fellow Avenger Hawkeye
was actually the designer of his weapons
which he did is part of a pact with
construe to allow Moon Knight to rescue
them and return them to the proper time
after this moon nights time with the
West Coast Avengers was somewhat tenuous
as he was not accustomed to functioning
as part of a team however a new romantic
relationship developed during this time
as moon I began dating Tigre something
else to note here is that moon nights
tender with the Avengers came to an end
after Mockingbird was drugged and
assaulted by the Phantom Rider which led
to Mockingbird
allowing him to be killed angry with the
decision Hawkeye ends his relationship
with her causing Mockingbird to leave
the team taking Tigre and moon night
with her after an encounter with hell
storm moon ight learns that khonshu had
actually possessed his body and as the
source of his powers which are at their
peak under the full moon due to khonshu
status as God of the moon it's further
explained that it was conscious decision
to join The Avengers not Marx as con she
wanted to battle his rival Seth who was
invading Asgard at the time after
learning this moon knife formally
resigns from the Avengers and ends his
relationship with Tigre furthermore
khonshu leaves much vectors body leaving
him effectively powerless continuing on
in 1989 moon knight would once again
star in his own solo series as Marvel
launched March Spectre moon night which
saw mark return in New York to try and
repair his relationships with Marlene
and Frenchie after Bushman kidnaps
Marlene mark decides that although he's
no longer in possession of his powers
he'll continue on in his role as moon
knight he also finds that he's more
mentally stable without conscious
presence in his mind and leaves his
steve grant and jake Lockley
personalities aside an important note
here is that this series saw a shift in
tone for moon knight as he now became
more of a street-level crime fighter due
to his lack of powers while this
would-be moon Knights longest running
series running 60 issues before being
canceled in 1994 it never actually found
its footing due to frequent changes and
writers as well as getting wrapped up in
crossovers such as infinity war and acts
of vengeance and so by the end of the
series Moon Knight sacrificed himself to
conscious arch-nemesis Seth in order to
save the lives of Marlene and Frenchie
as with most comic book characters
however moon knight did not stay dead
for long as he was resurrected by
khonshu in the 1998 miniseries
resurrection war written by co-creator
Doug mink in this story khonshu needed
moon knight to battle three of his
greatest foes RAL bushmen Morpheus and
black Specter all of whom had fallen
into Seth's service after this wound I
received another miniseries called hi
strangers also written by mink as well
as making sporadic appearances in other
comics such as Marvel Knights
Marvel team-up and Great Lakes Avengers
in 2006 however moon night is given yet
another ongoing series this time written
by Charlie Houston and drawn by David
Finch Houston's run on moon nights
signaled a dramatic shift in tone for
the Moon Knight character in addition to
depicting March Spectre as ultraviolent
Houston fully embraced spectres
previously hinted at psychological
problems this series opens on March
Spectre as a broken man both mentally
and
logically following a brutal battle with
Bushmen in addition to this Houston also
reckons March spectres history by
updating his timeline moving his time in
the Marine Corps up to the Gulf War and
his mercenary career in the 1990s this
run of Moon Knight also introduced
several key advancements in munites
narrative for instance Moon Knight is
finally able to gain a decisive victory
over Bushman who he kills in brutal
fashion
by removing its face with one of his
crescent darts this series also sees
frenchie reveal himself to be a
homosexual and professes love for Mark
and forces moon knight to confront his
former sidekick turns super villain who
Moon Knight kills in battle during the
events of civil war which required all
superhumans to register with the
government when marc spector submits his
application and size with tony stark is
assumed that he'll be turned down due to
his multiple personality disorder
however moon knight is able to channel
the power of khonshu to convince the
government psychiatrist to approve his
application allowing him to become part
of the fifty state initiative following
this Charlie Houston would turn writing
duties over to mark Vinson in issue
number fourteen who will continue to
influence the overall plot of the book
during this time khonshu once again
leaves mark Specter after declaring that
he has other servants and no longer
requires March service after this and
following an altercation with Norman
Osborn's Thunderbolts move Knight fakes
his death and moves to Mexico where it's
revealed that marks effectors
personality is now gone and Jake Lockley
has taken over control of marks mind
eventually and following the
cancellation of a solo series Edition
number 30 moon knight returns to the US
as Jake Lockley in the 10 issue series
titled vengeance of the Moon Knight in
2009 written by Greg Hurwitz who
attempted to paint moon Knights
character is more of a traditional
superhero during this time moon knight
seeks vengeance on Norman Osborn but
Osborn is able to use a super villain
the hood to resurrect Bushman after moon
not again defeats Bushman khonshu who
has returned to moon Knights conscience
timpz mark to kill Bushman once again
but Moon Knight resists the urge
instead send me Bushman to prison and so
after this Jake Lockley reunites with
Marlene as they try to forge a normal
life while this series was canceled
after only ten issues moon now remained
in the Marvel Universe by making
appearances and Ed Brubaker Secret
Avengers as well as the daredevil event
Shadowland during the Shadowland story
moon on is plagued by a mysterious
figure called the shadow knight who
kills Marlene and Jake's unborn child it
is later revealed that the shadow Knight
is actually March spectres brother
Randall and
nice revenge promising to kill Randall
and country's name in exchange for the
sapphire Crescent and artifact he needs
in order to destroy the shadow knight
and so after finding the Crescent in New
Orleans Moon Knight uses it to kill
Randall and then declares that Jake
Lockley is now dead and once again
assumes the identity of mark Specter
following this and 2011 Marvel revived
the Moon Knight franchise once again
this time under the writing of Brian
Michael Bendis with art by Alex meleave
and yet another dramatic shift for the
character Bendis move March Spectre to
Los Angeles where he's working on a
television series about Moon Knight
called The Legend of khonshu during this
time bindus adds new personalities to
Moon Knight psyche in the form of
Captain America spider-man and Wolverine
in addition to this Mark believes that
these three are not actually in his head
but are in fact present and fighting
alongside him however despite being held
by a popular creative team Moon Knight
series suffered from low sales and was
canceled after only 12 issues and so in
the time leading up to all-new
all-different marvel and 2014 as part of
the all-new Marvel now initiative which
saw large slates of new titles
introduced Moon Knight was given yet
another ongoing series this time written
by Warren Ellis with art by Declan
Shively by this time mu9 has returned to
New York and has adopted yet another
personality that of mr. Knight a
detective who helps local law
enforcement with their most unusual
cases as mr. Knight Spectre dresses in
an all-white suit as well as a mask so
that his enemies can see him coming it's
also revealed during a visit with March
psychiatrist he does not actually have
disassociative identity disorder as
previously thought but that has passed
multiple personalities were actually
different aspects of the god country the
Pathfinder the embrace her the defender
and in his more violent moments the one
who lives on hearts furthermore contries
possession of March spectres caused mark
to create multiple personalities to
explain what's happening to it which has
resulted in brain damage following this
Warren Ellis would leave the title after
six issues turning writing duties over
to Brian Wood who would subsequently
leave the title to be replaced by Cullen
Bunn and so following Jonathan Hickman
secret Wars Marvel launched many of
their titles with new number one issues
and what they Doug all-new all-different
marvel to this end moon knight was
relaunched with a seventh volume under
the writing of jeff lemire
in an interview with coming book
resources jeff lemire stated that he
wanted to draw on both the original run
on the care
by doug mink as well as Warren Ellis and
Declan Shively's more recent run he also
stated that he wanted to use the
character to explore the issue of mental
illness and to that end the first arc of
the series is set in a mental hospital
where moon at is joined by his old
allies
Marlene Frenchy and Crowley seemingly
managing to escape the mental facility
is unclear whether or not they were
actually there or whether the escape is
real or one of march SaLuSa Nations and
as the first arc has just wrapped up we
still do not have any answers to those
questions with that being said we're
going to bring this to an end I know
that with marc spector moon night it can
be very confusing simply because of the
fact that his character has been
rebooted and no one's really known what
to do with his multiple personalities
but in truth moon night is really just
Marvel's version of Batman he's painted
a different way but at the end of the
day it's all the same thing but fans
seem to have some kind of obsession with
him and I'm not really sure why but
anyway if you guys enjoyed this video
leave a like make sure you guys hit the
subscribe button to join part of the
robb core and I will catch you guys
later peace
[Music]